GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME I WOULD LIKE TO
CONVENE THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
UTILITIES AND ENERGY- SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BEFORE WE MOVED TO THE AGENDA I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE FIRST
IMMEDIATELY UPON A GERMAN OF
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING IN
THE CHAMBER. AS I ASK YOU TO
KEEP A RESPECTFUL PACE TO THIS
AFTERNOON RECOGNIZING WE HAVE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE FOLLOWING US.
SECONDLY WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO STEPPING IN FOR
SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO I THANK.
THE MEMBER CHAO FOR JOINING US
TODAY. THIRD I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBER. OR
REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTION MUTED. FINALLY
WELL WE ARE NO LONGER
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
DURING COMMITTEE HEARINGS. WE
ARE STILLWEARING MASKS AT ALL
TIMES HERE IN THE CHAMBER AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
OF THESE RULES AND KEEP YOUR
MASS ON AT ALL TIMES. WE HAVE A
FEW OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY IN THE
CHAMBER IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
IN THE GALLERY. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE CHAMBER WINESSES
WILL MAKE USE. OF OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED ON
THE NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS AREA CODE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO. FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. EIGHT YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE TELLY. ASSEMBLY UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON THE TELEVISION
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
POLICE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING.
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOUR
MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR BILL OR AGAINST
THE BILL. WE REMAIN ALIVE LINE
IT WILL NEED TO REMOVE YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT
THREE. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP. WE ARE ALSO- WE
ARE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE HAVE
SIX MEASURES ON THE AGENDA
TOURING CONSENT. THE CONSENT
ITEMS ARE ITEM TWO SB NINETY
NINE DODD. AND ITEM FIVE SP
FIVE THIRTY THREE STERN HAS
THREE PROCEED WITH THEIR
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFICIENT AND
FAIR HEARING. TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO FOUR MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ON A MEASURE PLEASE
BRIEFLY STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION AND-
I'D ALSO ASK THAT MEMBERS SPEAK
DIRECTLY INTO YOUR MICROPHONE
SO THE PUBLIC CAN HEAR YOUR
REPORTS VOTE VOTES- WE I
BELIEVE ARE STILL A LITTLE BIT
SHORT OF A QUORUM. AND SO WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS CONVENE AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND I'D LIKE TO-
BEGAN- WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE- SB
SIXTY EIGHT BECKER. A BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING SENATOR BAKER
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CARE MEMBERS. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT REDUCING THE BARRIERS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO HELP
US ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
UNFORTUNATE WHEN PEOPLE WANT TO
SWITCH TO ELECTRIC HEATING OR
INSTALL VEHICLE CHARGERS OR
ENERGY STORAGE EQUIPMENT
GOVERNMENT FACE HIGH COSTS AND
LONG DELAYS. WE NEED PEOPLE TO
BE MAKING THESE CHANGES SO WE
SHOULD MAKE IT A LOT EASIER FOR
THEM. TO DO SO. HI THIS BILL
ATTACKS THE BERRIES BY
PROVIDING BETTER INFORMATION.
AND SUPPORTING R&D EFFORTS FOR
TECHNOLOGY MAKE THIS CHEAPER
AND EASIER. FIRST IN
INFORMATION CONTRACTORS OFTEN
HAVE LITTLE EXPERIENCE WITH
ELECTRIC HEATING AND NEW
DEVICES. PEOPLE IN THE BEING
TALKED OUT OF ELECTRIFYING
BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DO IT OR THEY END
UP DOING COSTLY PANEL UPGRADES.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED.
LOCAL BUILDING DEPARTMENTS ALSO
MAKE IT UNNECESSARILY
EXPENSIVE. SO THIS BILL DIRECTS
ENERGY COMMISSION TO GATHER AND
PUBLISH BEST PRACTICES. TO HELP
GET BETTER INFORMATION OUT
THERE SO BUILDING OWNERS THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN DO THIS
MORE. EFFICIENTLY A SECOND
TECHNOLOGY WE NEED TO DRIVE
DOWN THE COST OF
ELECTRIFICATION- SOME
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN AVOID THE
NEED TO ACTUALLY FOR PANEL
UPGRADES. AND MAKE IT FASTER
AND EASIER TO HAVE HANDLES
UPGRADES IF NEEDED. BUT IT'S
RELATIVELY NEW AND NOT WIDELY
DEPLOYED AND IT'S AN AREA WHERE
ARE DEFINING COULD HELP. THIS
BUILDING ADDS TECHNOLOGY TO.
REDUCE THE COST OF BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION TO LIST OF
CHALLENGES THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED FOR AFFECT FUNDING.
COMBINED WE BELIEVE BETTER
INFORMATION BETTER TECHNOLOGY
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR OWNERS
TO LECTURE FIVE- ENERGY USE IN
BUILDINGS AND PROVIDE CHARGES
FOR THE VEHICLES SUPPORTING OUR
STATE GOALS. AT TO SUPPORT US
HERE TODAY WE HAVE TO WIN ESTES
HERE TO FORGE FROM ENERGY C.
AND CHEN PEPPER THE CO PENCIL
CLEAN ENERGY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MODERATOR WILL TURN TO
CHEN PEPPER WITH PENINSULA
CLEAN ENERGY YOU WILL PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. IF YOU'RE
ON THE LINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME RIKA. OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR HOLDEN AND HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM JAN
PEPPER CEO OF PENINSULA CLEAN
ENERGY AND WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THESE
COMMENTS TODAY. BUT IN FOR A
CLEAN ENERGY IS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY OF TWENTY TWO CITIES
TOWNS AND THE COUNTY RUNNING A
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATOR
PROGRAM SERVING ROUGHLY. SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AND SALMON TAIL
COUNTY AND EXPANDING TO LOS
BANOS AND WE'RE SAID COUNTY IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE ARE NOT
FOR PROFIT AGENCY AND PROVIDE
1100% CARBON FREE ELECTRICITY
TO ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS. IN
ADDITION WE DEVELOP AND
ADMINISTER LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
FURTHER REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY EXPANDING
EXPANDING BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING FOR ALL OF SAN
MATTEO COUNTIES RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES. WE FUND THESE
PROGRAMS BY REINVESTING OUR
REVENUES INTO ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY. OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
SUPPORTED OUR MEMBER CITIES TO
ADOPT LOCAL REACH CODES FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO TRANSITION FROM
NATURAL GAS TO CLEAN
ELECTRICITY. FOR SPACE AND
WATER HEATING AND PROVIDE FOR
EASY CHARGERS. SO FAR- LEVIN
OVER TWENTY ONE MEMBER AGENCIES
IN THE COUNTY HAVE ADOPTED
THESE REACH CODES WHICH
REPRESENT A QUARTER OF THE
STATE'S TOTAL WITH MORE IN
PROGRESS. YOUR THIS WORK WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED NUMEROUS
BARRIERS INCLUDING THE NEED FOR
MORE EDUCATION AMONG
PRACTITIONERS AND THE CHALLENGE
OF LONG TIME LINES FOR UTILITY
SERVICE WORK. SOME CITIES HAVE
DELAYED ADOPTING REACH CODES
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS FROM
RESIDENTS ABOUT DELAYS. OF
THREE TO EIGHT MONTHS FOR PG&E
TO RESPOND TO INCOMPLETE
ROUTINE SERVICE UPGRADE REQUEST.
SB SIXTY EIGHT WILL HELP US DO
MORE THE BILL WILL HAVE THE CDC
AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES
PROVIDE GUIDANCE AND BEST
PRACTICES. THIS BILL WILL FIND
MORE WORK TO BRING INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES TO THE MARKET
FASTER AND THIS BILL WILL HELP
BUILDING OWNERS GET UPGRADES
AND FASTER AND AT LESS COST. WE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE STATE TO
REDUCE THE CARBON FOOTPRINT OF
OUR BUILDING AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE. I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT
SB SIXTY EIGHT AND WANT TO
THANK SENATOR BECKER. AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT AND SB
SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU OUR NEXT WITNESSES PIERRE
DAHLE FORGE WITHIN OUR DC YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU TO HOLDEN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
MIAMI GATHER FOR SOME OF THE
FACTORS WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL OR
NRDC. TESTIFYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY EIGHT. THIS
BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD IN CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING THE
CLIMATE AND AIR POLLUTION
EMITTED BY ITS BUILDINGS AND
TRANSPORTATION. ELECTRIFICATION
OF HEATING EQUIPMENT AND CALL
IT A KEY STRATEGY FOR THE
COMPANY I THINK CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY CANNOT AFFORDABLE
MANNER. AND FOR REDUCING THAT
POLLUTION IN UPSTATE. HOWEVER
ONE OF THE KEY CHALLENGES
FACING HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT TO
ELECTRIFY THE BUILDINGS AND
VEHICLES AND THE BUILDING
PROFESSIONALS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO SUPPORT THEM.
IF THE LACK OF CLEAR AND EASILY
ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION ABOUT
COST EFFECTIVE ELECTRIFICATION
STRATEGIES. PARTICULARLY ON HOW
TO AVOID COSTLY ELECTRIC PANEL
UPGRADE. WHICH ARE A MAJOR COST
FACTOR. THEY ALSO NEED TO
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION TO BETTER
MANAGE GROWING ELECTRIC LOADS
WITHOUT INFLICTING GREAT COST.
THIS BILL IDENTIFIED AND
REDUCES BARRIERS TO HOMEOWNERS
WHO WANT TO TRANSITION TO USING
CLEAN ELECTRICITY TO HEAT THEIR
HOMES AND SHOT THAT CAUGHT.
DEVELOPING AN MAKING ACCESSIBLE
GUIDANCE AND BEST PRACTICES TO
BETTER ENABLE CALIFORNIANS TO
OVERCOME THESE BARRIERS. IF THE
VITAL TO MAKING PROGRESS ON
REDUCING EMISSIONS AND ALL
STATE. DIRECTING RESEARCH FUNDS
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM WOULD
LOWER THE COST OF THE
TRANSITION TO CLEAN ENERGY IN
BUILDINGS AND VEHICLES FOR
EVERYONE. THE BILL MAKES
PROGRESS FUNDED ISSUES BY
BETTER UTILIZING AND MAKING
ACCEPTABLE EXISTING FUNDING AND
EXPERTISE. THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO FORMAL OPPOSITION
LISTED FOR THIS BILL SO WILL
NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON SB SIXTY EIGHT IN
THE CHAMBERS. SEEING NONE- ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE SEVEN
SERVICE CENTER FIFTEEN NON.
PHONE MODERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE PLEASE HAVE BEEN
STATE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. SURE IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF S.
B. SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ATTENDED VERO AND OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER BUT
YOU BACKING Q. ONCE AGAIN THAT
IS THE ONE THAT RURAL FOR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY EIGHT. AND WE LOOK LIKE
WE HAVE ABOUT SIX PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE. YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
START WITH LINE. SEVENTY NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DENNIS DIGICABLE CHIP
WOULD CALIFORNIA'S VISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY AND SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE. EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JEANNIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TWENTY FIFTH
EXCHANGING CAL FIFTY EIGHT AS
WELL AS AND C. E. SERVING
CUSTOMERS IN NAPA SOLANO AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY RETALIATES.
AND THEN LASTLY ON BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA'S VERSION P.
AND COMMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY HIM LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JOANNA
PAULA AND ON BEHALF OF MY MOST
PART WE SUPPORT A FEW
SUPPORTIVE SB SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LEVEL GO TO
LINE NUMBER. EIGHTY FIVE. HELLO
MY NAME IS A MARLINGTON TOKYO
AND LIVED IN NEW YORK
CALIFORNIA AND I'M GOING TO I'M
GONNA WITH THE MEMO SPARKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY EIGHT. R.
SIXTY NINE SORRY. SIXTY EIGHT I
BELIEVE. IF YOU COULD. YEAH.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER. NINETY CAROL WE NEED
APPROVAL AND ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
SB SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
PERSON QUEUING UP SO IT'LL TAKE
A MINUTE HERE TO GET THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AND ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO.
SO SOMEONE
WAITING TO TEE UP HERE OR WE.
WHERE ARE WE MODERATOR.
MODERATOR YEAH NOW I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY THREE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU CAN STONE
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY. THIS IS USE
THAT MILLER WITH SENIOR FOR
KIDS AND THE NORTH COUNTY SAN
DIEGO NWC P. BY THE CLOSE OF
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT SB. SIX
THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIR WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU A CENTER
BEFORE WE BRING IT BACK FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM NOW SO WE'RE
GOING TO ASK SECRETARY TO CALL
THE ROLL AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
HOLDEN PRESIDENT. HOLDEN HAIR
PATTERSON. THERE CAN. ARE QUE
HAND HERE BURKE RIO. CARILLO
HERE CHOW CHOW HERE CHEN CHEN
HERE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HERE
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA
MAYES MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
HERE QUIRK CORK HERE RAYOS.
REYES HERE KING KING HERE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM
ASSUMES TEN. OKAY SO WE'LL COME
BACK TO COMMITTEE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ON CENTERS BILL
SUMMER CITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANTED TO- THANK CENTER
BECKER FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FOR TO ADDRESS
IT IN. TWO MAJOR SOURCES OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS ARE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AS WELL
AS OUR BUILDINGS AND SO- I-
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION AND
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THAT
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
BILL. REMOVED BY- THIS MESSAGE.
AND SECOND BY THIS RACE. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. HELLO YOU DO HAVE A
QUESTION OKAY. WE HAVE A
QUESTION FROM AN ARREST. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE CENTER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK THERE'S A MOVE FORWARD.
TOWARDS CLEAN ENERGY IN THE
FUTURE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT BUILDINGS ARE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
IT'S CLEAR THAT ELECTRIFYING.
TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDINGS
NEED TO GO HAND IN HAND AND I
THINK THAT LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE
ALWAYS CITING THE COST. AND IF
THE BILL IS NOT GOING TO
PROVIDE THE GUIDANCE THAT FOLKS
DO NEED. TO OVERCOME THESE
ISSUES ONE WITH THE NEW
BUILDINGS IN OLD BUILDINGS AND
EVERYTHING RELATED TO THE
TRANSPORTATION AND- BUILDINGS I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK
YOU IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED AND- WE HAVE. SKOREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NINETY
WANTED THANK- THE GOOD SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
FORWARD I REALLY ENJOY
LEGISLATION THAT HAS
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WE NEED THAT AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT SECTORS OF THE WORK
THAT WE DO HERE IN THE STATE
FOR THE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE TO
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME AND
SPECIFICALLY BEING ABLE TO GO
TO THE WEBSITE LOOK AT DATA SEE
WHERE DATA CAN LEAD US TOWARDS
THE FUTURE TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE ENERGY
GOALS AND CLEAN ENERGY GOALS I
THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. I REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT IS ALSO 20% BELOW
THE NATIONAL POVERTY LINE AND
FOR ME BEING ABLE TO BRING
THESE TYPES OF RESOURCES INTO
MY COMMUNITY AND TO BE ABLE TO
SAY YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY A ROLE A
CRITICAL ROLE IN ENSURING THAT
WE ARE REDUCING OUR FOSSIL FUEL
RELIANCE AS WELL AS CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE OFTEN IGNORED IN THIS
CONVERSATION TOWARDS- THE
FUTURE OF OUR STATE IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
THE DATA WILL BE ALSO BE ABLE
TO SHOW US IT'S NOT ONLY
AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
GETTING P. OPPORTUNITIES BUT WE
NEED TO PIVOT AND SHIFT SO THE
DIRECTION ALSO INCLUDES. RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN URBAN AREAS
WHERE THIS CONVERSATION IS
ALMOST NONEXISTENT SO I THINK
THIS IS A AN INCREDIBLE A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION ON COLLECTING
DATA AND I TO IF POSSIBLE WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR YOU HAVE A BILL THAT
HAS STRUCK AT THE HEART OF.
WHAT IS. FUNDAMENTAL TO A LOT
OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS. OF THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I THINK A FOR A THANK
YOU ALL FOR THOSE COMMENTS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. I REMEMBER WHEN SB
SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS. HOLDEN
FIVE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON. OUR
QUE HAN R. K. HAD AYE BURKE
AREA CARRILLO I'D CHAO CHAO AYE
CHAN CHAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES MAYES AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I REYES REYES I CHIANG.
CHIANG I WENT. TO AT ELEVEN IS
YOUR YOUR BILL IS NOT YOUR
BILLS OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT ARE SCARED ME
MISTER CHAIR I'M SORRY.
PATTERSON'S I. THAT'S. TWO
TWELVE ZERO YOU'RE STILL YOUR
BILL IS STILL OUT OF COMMITTEES.
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR OF
THE MEMBERS- BEFORE WE MOVE TO
OUR NEXT ITEM WE HAVE WILL
RECOGNIZE SENATOR DODD IF WE
COULD TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM FIVE. WELL WITH
THE C. ITEM. TO WHICH IS SB
NINETY NINE DIED. AT AN ITEM
FIVE S. B. FIVE THIRTY THREE
STERN. IT'S BEEN MOVED. I THE
NUMBER TWO SB NINETY AT NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO JUDICIARY. HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
I PATTERSON. PATTERSON I PARA
QUE HAN PARA QUE HAN I BURKE.
RIO CARILLO IHL OUR AYE CHAN.
GEN I CUNNINGHAM. THE CONSENT
ITEMS. CUNNINGHAM I'D CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA MAYES.
MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI MASUCCI I
QUIRK. QUIRK I REYES REYES I
TíNH TING HI. IS TWELVE NO
ZERO. THE CONSECUTIVE CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED- WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN AND LET THE RECORD
SHOW THAT MR PATTERSON CHRYSLER
VICE CHAIR PATTERSON MADE A
MOTION SECOND VIRUS. I WILL NOW
TURN TO ITEM THREE SB- TO
TWENTY TWO DODD WATER RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. SENATOR
THAT YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. SB BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS. MEMBERS
SB TWO TWO TWO WOULD ESTABLISH
THE WATER RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM TO HELP PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE FOR BOTH DRINKING
AND WASTEWATER SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME RATEPAYERS EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS. SOME OF YOU
MAY RECALL IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I AUTHORED LEGISLATION
AB FOUR OH ONE ASKED THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
STUDY THE ISSUE OF A LOW INCOME
WATER RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
OR WATER ZERO. THE BOARD IS
DONE THAT IN SB TWO TWO TWO
TAKES THE NEXT STEP OF MOVING
FORWARD TO ENACT SUCH A PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION TO COMPLETING THE
WATER LIVER STUDY THE WATER
BOARD RECENTLY SURVEYED
HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS AROUND THE STATE TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH WATER DEBT.
WATER GET WATER SYSTEM
CUSTOMERS WERE CREWING. AND THE
RESULTS WERE VERY WELL. FRANKLY
INCREDIBLY SOBERING. EXAMPLES
OF HOW SERIOUS THE PROBLEM OF
WATER UNAFFORDABILITY HAS
ACTUALLY BECOME. OVER ONE AND A
HALF MILLION HOUSEHOLDS ARE
BEHIND ON THEIR WATER BILLS
THAT'S OVER FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR CLEAN
SAFE DRINKING AND WASTEWATER.
12% OF CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE A DEBT OF AT LEAST FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND OF
THESE HOUSEHOLDS HAVE DEBT
GREATER THAN A THOUSAND
DOLLARS. Q. MINIMALLY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCRUED ABOUT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF WATER
DEBT AND THAT NUMBER IS
INCREASING ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH. IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN PRE
PANDEMIC OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAD
ALREADY LOST THEIR WATER
SERVICE DUE TO THE INABILITY TO
PAY WATER BILLS. THE NUMBER HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. GROWING WATER
DEBT IS ALSO A PROBLEM FOR
WATER SYSTEMS SOME WATER
SYSTEMS OF WATCHED AS MUCH AS
30% OF THE REVENUE. AND MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS ARE
FACING FINANCIAL COLLAPSE DUE
TO THE INABILITY OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS TO PAY WATER BILLS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOW INCOME
RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS
UTILITIES. IN NOT WITHSTANDING
STATE POLICY THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. THERE IS NO COMPARABLE
WATER RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
FOR PUBLICLY OWNED AND
COMMUNITY OWNED WATER SYSTEMS.
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE HAVE A STATE
WIDE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE TO PAY FOR
DRINKING AND WASTEWATER. SB TWO
TWO TWO IS NARROWING ITS FOCUS
ON DIRECT WATER RESISTANCE.
WATER CRISIS ASSISTANCE AND
RENTER'S CREDIT. THE BILL
REQUIRES THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP AN
EXPENDITURE PLAN THAT WOULD
IDENTIFY THE FUNDING THE FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. WELL I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR-
BEFORE HE PROPOSED A ONE
BILLION DOLLARS WATER DEBT
RELIEF THE TRUTH IS THE PROBLEM
WATER AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WILL PERSIST.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IDENTIFY A
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
RESISTANCE PROGRAM THAT IS A
PARALLEL CONVERSATIONS
BEGINNING TO TAKE PLACE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION. I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE WHO ARE
READY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. IT AT THE PROPER TIME
MISTER GERALD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
CRITICALLY NEEDED PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD WILL
TURN TO OUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
RECOGNIZE JENNIFER CLARY OF
CLEAN WATER ACTION YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CLARY AND I'M THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION OUR ORGANIZATION
IS A SPONSOR CONNECT UP TO
TWENTY TWO I AM ALSO SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW
SPONSORING ORGANIZATION.
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN ARMS ARE
GOING TO PATIENTS STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT YOU
FINALLY PUT INTO PLACE A
FRAMEWORK FOR COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE LOW INCOME WATER MADE%
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE OUR YEARS
ADVOCATING FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER HAVE TARGETED MAKING
WATER SAFE IS ONLY HALF THE
BATTLE IT HOUSEHOLDS COMMUNITY
CAN'T AFFORD THE WATER FROM
THEIR TAPS THE WATER IS STILL
NOT ACCEPTABLE. THE WATERGATE
CRISIS GENERATED BY THE
PANDEMIC ALSO HIGHLIGHTED A
LONG STANDING PROBLEM THE
SAFETY NET THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
FOR OTHER UTILITIES ARE
VIRTUALLY NONEXISTENT FOR THOSE
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR WATER
BILLS. FOR INSTANCE ONLY ABOUT
HALF OF THE STATE'S POPULATION
IT SERVED BY PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEM THAT EVEN OFFERS A LOW
INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE LIMITED
ENROLLMENT. LARGELY BECAUSE THE
COUNTRY TEAM REQUIREMENTS THE
RESULT IS THAT FEW ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS ACTUALLY BEAT THE
SYSTEM. OUR WATER BILL. IN
EXCEPTION. THE COMMISSION TO
THEY'RE NOT SUBJECT TO
PUNCTUATE CHANGE AND THREE THEY
ALSO REGULARLY SHARE
ELIGIBILITY DATA WITH INVESTOR
OWNED ENERGY UTILITY IT. IS
LONG STANDING AFFORDABILITY
PROGRAM AND ROLE MORE THAN 80%
OF ELIGIBLE HOSPITALS. WATER
PHILIP APPLICABILITY AS AN
ISSUE IN EVERY PART OF THE
STATE MALRAUX COMMUNITIES
SUBURBS URBAN CENTERS. STATE
ACTION IS NEEDED TO BRIDGES
AFFORDABILITY GAP SENATE BILL
G. TWENTY TO CREATE A POT FULL
AND TRANSPARENT FRAMEWORK FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM. THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
WITH THIS IS BRITNEY RIVAS LOS
ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR NEW
ECONOMY. YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. I THANK YOU
SHAREHOLDING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NAME OF THE RESTAURANT ON THE
WATER CONTAINS NEW ORGANIZER
FOR LOS ANGELES LINE RENAUD
KIND OF NONPROFIT ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND RACIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION IS A
SUPPORTER OF THE SPELL GIVEN
THE WORK WITH THE REPAIR EARLY
COALITION ALLEY D. W. P. AB
ALTHOUGH RESEARCH ON WATER
ACCESS AND THE HUNDREDS OF
WATER TO CONSTRUCT A FENDER
COUNTY. DIRECTOR WE KNOW
MILLIONS OF L. A. COUNTY
RESIDENTS ARE IMPACTED BY THE
COST OF THE UTILITY UCLA
ESTIMATES ONE IN THREE
ANGELENOS HAVE WATER AND POWER
IT BACK AND YOU'LL BE BORNE BY
LIKE TEANECK AND BLACK
HOUSEHOLD. INCOME LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THIS JUMPS
TO MORE THAN HALF OF RESIDENTS.
L. E. W. P. CUSTOMERS ARE
FORTUNATE IN SO FAR AS LADWP
HAVE LOW INCOME. PROGRAMS FOR
OTHER AND- YOU REACH AND TWENTY
RESEARCH HAVE PUT THE MAGICIAN
ON THE- GO UP AT THE SKY. FOR
EXAMPLE. WEBER HOW A BILLION L.
THAT ACCOUNTS ARE CURRENTLY
INTO PULLING. OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. AND ABOUT 80% OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS ARE NOT INVOLVED IN
THE EXISTING LOW INCOME
PROGRAM. EVERY POWER LA TOWN
HALL EARLIER THIS MONTH THE
PRESIDENT SPOKE MOVINGLY ABOUT
THEIR STRUGGLES BOTH BEFORE AN
EXAGGERATED FIGHT THE PANDEMIC.
YOU HAVE A RESCUE THIRTY FOLD
GOOD AND MEDICAL EXPENSES.
NEVER REDUCE OF THE COUNTY WE
KNOW FROM TOO MANY
ORGANIZATIONS STEPPED OUT TO
THE PEOPLE OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS. DO NOT
HAVE REPAIRS IN PROGRAMS AT ANY
TIME. FINALLY THRIVENT ARE
BEING EXTREMELY HIGH RATE FOR
THE WATER AS WELL AS THE SCENE
WATER QUALITY ISSUES EXISTING
PROGRAMS LIKE WHY HE- ARE NOT
ABLE TO DRIVE RESIDENCE WATER
THAT. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO OUR
ALEX YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE FOR YEARS AND FOR
THE LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR DODD.
AND THE BILL'S CO OPERATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE-
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE HAVE NOW TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO TESTIFYING BY PHONE PHONE
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN ALERT
CINDY TALK WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
YOU MAY. PROCEED WITH HER
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU TERRY
HOLDEN IN MEMBERS CINDY TECH
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON SB TWO TWO TWO. WE
AGREE WITH SENATOR DODD THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A WATER LOW
INCOME WATER RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA. THE JUNE
SEVENTEENTH VERSION OF THE BILL
ADDRESSED ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE RAISED AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT SENATOR DODD HAS BEEN
MAKING AMENDMENTS. TO MAKE THE
BILL MORE WORKABLE. I'D LIKE TO
RAISE TWO ISSUES TODAY THE
FIRST IS IN SECTION ONE ONE SIX
NINE THREE ONE POINT ONE- SEE
THAT'S ON PAGE SIX. THIS
PROVISION WOULD HAVE THE FUND
EXPENDITURE PLAN IDENTIFIED THE
FUNDING NEEDS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS EVIDENTLY ACROSS THE
STATE IT'S UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHAT
THIS PROVISION WOULD BE USED
FOR OVER HOW WE OPERATE. WE
THINK THERE IS A MORE EFFICIENT
WAY TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
SUBSIDY UNDER THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE WE HAD A MEETING WITH
THE DOCTOR STAFF AND SPONSORS
LAST- GET THE END OF LAST WEEK.
AND THEY ARE WILLING TO WORK ON
THAT ISSUE SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO TRYING TO GET THAT ISSUE
WORKED OUT THANK YOU FOR THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
SECOND ISSUE IS- REGARDING
SECTION ONE ONE SIX NINE THREE
ONE POINT ONE TWO. THAT HAS TO
DO WITH THE- PROPOSAL WHERE THE
P. YOU SEE WOULD DEVELOP A
MECHANISM. FOR THE ELECTRIC AND
GAS CORPORATIONS TO SHARE THEIR
CUSTOMER DATA. AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT- COMMITTEES
WORK IN THE OFFICE WORK ON THE
PRIVACY PART OF THAT. BUT- OUR
CONCERN IS THAT WE THINK THE
STATE ALREADY KNOWS INCOME
LEVELS FOR HOUSEHOLD. SO IS
THIS REALLY NEEDED IT THANK THE
CONCERNED ABOUT CARE IS THAT
THE ENROLLMENT ELIGIBILITY DOES
NOT HAVE RIGOROUS VERIFICATION.
SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
CORPORATE THERE SO WE SUGGEST
DELETING THAT PROVISION OR
LATER COVERS THE OTHER
REMAINING ISSUES THAT WE HAVE.
IN AGAIN WE APPRECIATE SENATOR
DODD- YEAH AND THAT TEAM THAT
HE HAS WORKING ON THIS- WORKING
WITH THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. WILL TURN TO
NIKOLINA FERNANDES WITH SEMPER.
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU CAN
MEMBERS NICKEL AT THAT CENTER
ENERGY AND THAT ALTHOUGH WE DO
NOT HAVE A FORMAL LETTER OF
OPPOSITION SUBMITTED WE DID
RAISE THAT LIMITATION CONCERNS
WITH THE AUTHORED MAINLY
RELATED TO PRIVACY AND ALSO THE
DEFINITION OF LOW INCOME LIKE
THE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED- THE
BILL REQUIRES. ELECTRICAL
OPERATIONS TO SHARE CUSTOMER
ENROLLMENT DATA OUT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT. AND
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS
DISCUSSES THIS ISSUE IS THAT
JACKSON SHOULD INFORMATION
PRIVACY ACT WHICH WE DO NOT
OBJECT TO IT BUT- IN ORDER TO
PROTECT CUSTOMER
CONFIDENTIALITY IT IS BEST
PRACTICES TO CLARIFY WHAT TYPE
OF DATA. IS BEING SHARED
SECURELY SO. TEMPERATURES BUT-
WHAT THE CUSTOMER HI
INFORMATION IS THE DATA THAT'S
BEING SHARED. AND THEN BECAUSE
IT'S LIKELY THAT ARE CARE
COVERAGE THEY RECEIVE OUTRAGE
BY THE DEPARTMENT- ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS WE NEED PROTECTION
FROM THAT DIRECT MARKETING ALSO
KNOWN AS THE SUNSHINE ACT.
WHILE I'M AT THE OTHER THAT
RECOMMEND WONDER THANK- THE
CARE CUSTOMER CONTACT
INFORMATION THAT IS SHARED WITH
pFOR PURPOSES THAT- THIRD PARTY
DIRECT MARKETING UNDER CIVIL
CODE SECTION ONE. SEVEN NINETY
THREE POINT EIGHT THREE. AND I
FOR THE LOW INCOME DEFINITION-
AB FOR IMPLEMENTATION-
CONSIDERATION. NOW WE DO NOT
HAVE THEM- INFORMATION BASE ON
A MEETING HOUSEHOLD- THE CARE
ELIGIBLE IS BASED ON THE
FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINES SO
AS THAT. OPERABLE COMMITTEE
SHOULD THE- KIDDING FATHER WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE AT THE
GYM I KNOW WHAT YOU REALLY NEED
TO BE ATKINS. ALIGNED WITH BACK
TO ENSURE WE COORDINATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION. I JUST AS THE
FINAL REMARK ON IT THINK THE
OTHER STAFF- FOR THE BUBBLE
CONSIDERATION WE DO SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL CUSTOMERS
AND OTHER CUSTOMERS AB
HARDSHIPS. AGAIN WE'RE NOT
FORMALLY OPPOSED BUT YOU HOPE
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OTHER AND CAPTAIN JACK THESE
TECHNICAL. AND OPERATIONAL
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOR NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC COM ANY
SO OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON S.
B. TWO TWENTY TWO AND THE
CHAMBERS C. NINE AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES AT
MODERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE. CAN PLACE IF YOU ARE
AN- GO AHEAD. ABOUT THAT IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
S. B. TO PUSH ONE THEN ZERO.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE
ABOUT SEVENTEEN IN QUEUE. WE
WILL START WITH ONE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH WE'RE
GONNA BE DEALING OPPORTUNITIES
I MEAN RIGHT NOW THE AT LEAST
ON THE SENATE SIDE THEY'RE NOT
TAKING IT PERSONALLY ONE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOW I'M
SORRY MAYBE I WASN'T CLEAR
WE'RE ONLY A RECEIVING
TESTIMONY BY WITNESSES STATING
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. OKAY NEXT LEVEL TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS BENJAMIN
TRIED WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE. LA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT RIVER BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRYAN SODIO
AND I'M THE MAYOR PHILIP
GLANVILLE CALLING FOR. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS THIS
IS READ ADDED ON BEHALF OF
CENTRAL COAST ENERGY SERVICES
AND TEN LOW INCOME SERVICE
PROVIDERS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
WELL WE'VE BEEN SEEKING A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT WE'RE VERY
STRONG SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MATURE NUMBERS TO KEEP A
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO HAVE A BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PLAN TRACKING THE TOP
PATENT PRICE REPRESENTING THE
WATER FOUNDATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HAVE A PHOTO LINE NUMBER. ONE
TWENTY FIVE ONE TWENTY FIVE. HI
THIS IS EVAN MAINTAIN WITH
VOICES FOR PROGRESS WE HAVE A
PRIORITY SUPPORT POSITION ON
THE IMPORTANT BALLOT. THANK YOU
NEXT TO BOTTOM LINE NUMBER ONE
NINETEEN. IF GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CHRIS HOGAN RAZA CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND CALLING ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER FILLON POVERTY
IN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER
ALLIANCE- COMING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
NINETY TWO. THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS TO ANSWER WITH THE WITH
THE WHITE MAN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICE
COMPANY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE OH EIGHT. MY NUMBER. ONE OH
EIGHT. HELLO JENNIFER PARTS OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER. NINETY
SIX. NUMBER YEAH ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF YOUR YOU CAN ABILITY
NONPROFIT THAT RUNS THE
BUSINESS FOR INNOVATIVE CLIMATE
AND ENERGY POLICY NETWORK IN
SUPPORT OF TWO TWO TWO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL GO
TO A LINE NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
IF GO HEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ
BUT UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBER ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON OF THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER.
SIXTY SIX ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR IN THIS IS GREG MORRISON
ON BEHALF OF THE ALL STAR
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
WE HAVE A POSITION OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD THERE
SHOULD BE SOME OPTION FOR
AGENCIES THAT HAVE NON
RATEPAYER FUNDED NON TAX
FUNDED. LOW INCOME RANGE SORRY
BECAUSE I'M NINE THEY JUST NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
MOVE ON TO NEXT PICKER THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HANNAH
DAVIDSON ON BEHALF OF THE
HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICT WE ALIGN OUR
OPPOSITION WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU WE WANT TO LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANIEL SENT
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
WATER HEATERS THAT WORK
REPRESENTING FOURTEEN CITIES
AND COMMUNITIES AND TULARE KERN
AND KINGS COUNTY WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO
TWO. THANK YOU NOW WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KERN RIVER
WITH SOME COMPANY WATERSHED
ALLIANCE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COALITION FOR WATER IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WILL BE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN THAT'S FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DOMINIQUE RAFI ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNMENT VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THEN WHAT DID YOU. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REALLY LOPEZ
ON BEHALF THE ONE THAT I WATER
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION YEAH.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL BE LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY APPLE THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU SHERMAN PURSUIT IS HELPING
OUT WITH THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER COMMUNITY BASED
ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT APART
BECAUSE SPONSORED BILL
FINANCIAL SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
G. TWO ALSO LIKE TO REGISTER
SINCE THE SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
OUR CLIENTS THAT CAN CALL IN
TODAY. THE PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR NURSES FOR A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE OH TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. USE THAT MILLER
WITH THE NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO
AND DOUBLE ACP ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE AND CLEAN
ARTS FOR KIDS ENFORCEABLE. MY
NUMBER ONE GOAL UP SOME THIRTY
FIFTY ONE REPLY NUMBER FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU ARE
NOT TAKING PART ON BEHALF OF
THE IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT
IN EAST VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
CONSISTENT WITH NINETY TALK
ABOUT QUICK COMMENT. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A WATER LINE NUMBER.
WHAT BY NUMBER ONE THIRTY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON WRECK CAL
YELLOW ON BEHALF OF DESERT
WATER AGENCY- DRIVER RETENTION
DISTRICT IN PALMDALE WATER
DISTRICT- WITH EIGHT OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
NEXT IN LINE WILL BE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANTHONY MOLINA
ON BEHALF OF MESA WATER
DISTRICT AND THE TWELVE
UTILITIES DISTRICT WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER ONE OF FOURTEEN THE LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NOT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT HERE
ON BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
PROJECTS NOT ACCOUNTABILITY
COUNTING- CALLING IN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TEACHERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WILL
BE LINE AT NUMBER SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS NO
LONGER WITH THE CITY OF FRISCO
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH AQUA. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER EIGHTY THREE THE LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS HE WENT ON
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WHY NUMBER ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY MY NUMBER ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF G. MINOR
ON BEHALF OF AT IN A MARGARITA
WATER DISTRICT OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
LINE WILL BE ONE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LOOTER
PEOPLE MY NAME IS KEVIN ALLEN
I'VE BEEN WITH THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS. AND I APPROVED THE BILL.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT WILL BE LINE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
BASKETBALL ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT WERE POSING WITH
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOW IT WILL BE LINE NUMBER OF
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN ONE LOOK FOR
THE COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS
ALLIANCE. AND THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA SECTION OF THE AMERICAN
WATER WORKS ASSOCIATION. IN
LINE WITH THE TOP OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AT BETWEEN.
TWENTY TWO AND LISTEN AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND OUR
LAST ONE IN Q. HERE'S WHY
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MIGHT HAVE A
FUN MUTE. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE SIXTEEN WITH CUBA GO
AHEAD PLEASE. I'M TOM GOD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY ACTION
PARTNERSHIP ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
THANK YOU AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL THOSE WHO CALLED
IN TO ASSURE THEIR- THEIR
COMMENTS AND THOUGHTS AS WE
BRING THIS BACK TO COMMITTEE.
AND- IT'S BEEN MOVED BY DR KIRK
FIVE SECOND BY ARCADIA- JUST
FOR THE RECORD I THINK WE HEARD
YOU EARLIER SAY THAT YOU ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THEY GO TO ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES OF PRIVACY AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY COMPLY WITH
WHAT'S CALLED OUT IN THE-
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT AND
THOSE WILL BE MAINTAINED IN
THIS BILL SO- AND ALSO STRIKING
OUT THE LIABILITY WAIVER FOR PO
USE. IF THIS IF THEY MISHANDLE
DATA SO THAT'S- THE AMENDMENT
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
FOR THE AUTHOR. SAYING NINE. OF
SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR CALL
THE ROLL. I REMEMBER THREE SB
TO PASS THE MANDATORY
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
AYE PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOT
VOTING BARRICADE. PARA QUE
HANNAH I BURKE CARILLO. I SHALL
CHAU I'D CHEN. CHEN NOT VOTING
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I MAYES MAYES I
MURATSUCHI PURSUE GI QUIRK. I
REYES REYES I TEAM KING I'D. IS
ELEVEN NOES. ZERO THE MOTION
CARRIES AND THE BILLS OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. ARE WE ARE
I UNDERSTAND SENATOR STERN IS
PRESENTING COMMITTEE SO WE'LL
MOVE TO ITEM SIX SB SIXTY SIX
NINETY FOUR BRADFORD FIRE
PREVENTION ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS. WHILE FOR
MITIGATION PLAN WORKFORCE
DIVERSITY WELCOME CENTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PROJECT SB
SIX NINE FOUR WHICH IS A
MEASURE THAT CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONSERVATION
CORPS MEMBERS TO JOIN US
UTILITIES. BEFORE COMING TO A
LEGISLATURE MY PAST LIFE I
SERVED AS PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
ELLIE CONSERVATION CORPS FOR
FOUR YEARS YOU GIVE ME
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET SOME
AMAZING YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
WHO. WORKED AND OUR NATURAL FOR
SYRIA WORKED IN OUR URBAN
GARDEN PLANTING TREES YOU NAME
IT BUT THEY HAD A REAL
COMMITMENT TO WORK AND CHANGE
YOUR LIFE FOR THOSE WHO HAD
SOME CHALLENGES THIS BILL
REQUIRES INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. DESCRIBE AND GIVE
DATA. THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS I'M PART OF EXISTING
REPORTING PROCESS- IT INCLUDES
BUT NOT LIMITED TO HOW
UTILITIES WORKING WITH AND
RECRUITING FROM CONSERVATION
CHORDS AS WELL AS FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. WHO
WORK FOR CDC ARE A FIRE CAMPS-
DEFEATED AGO WHILE FOR SEARCH
ADVISORY BOARD ISSUED A FINAL
RECOMMENDATION ON UTILITIES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHILE FAR
MITIGATION PLANS- THIS
INDEPENDENT BOARD OF EXPERTS
RECOGNIZED TO CONTINUE
CHALLENGE. OF A SCARCE LABOR
FORCE THAT WE KNOW IS NEEDED
BUT DOESN'T EXIST AS WELL AS
THE NEED FOR MORE WORK TO
ENSURE SUS SUFFICIENT. AND
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE MEMBERS
WERE CLEARLY STILL STILL WE
STILL NEED MORE EXPERIENCE
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK. AND
PREVENT FIRES THIS BILL WILL
HELP MEET THIS NEED BY BUILDING
A PIPELINE OF SKILLED AND
AVAILABLE WORKERS. AND I
RESPECT WILSHIRE AYE VOTE AND
TODAY- HERE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE SITUATION OF.
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS IS IN
ITS PRESIDENT WHEN THE BUT YOU
CAN JOIN US HERE TODAY AS. OUR
LOBBYIST READ US. BURGER WELL.
OKAY I WASN'T ABLE TO CATCH IT
EARLY ON BUT THE MOISTURE AND
ALREADY MOVED AND- WILL
RECEIVE- CRISTINA GARCIA
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA AS A
SECOND AND WE WILL NOW TURN TO
YOUR YOUR LEAVE WITNESS- READ
ADDIS WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES YOUR PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS READ
OUT US- ON THE ACTUAL BOSS
ANGELS CONSERVATION CORPS IN
THE POSITION OF COURSE
REQUESTED CALIFORNIA. REALLY
APPRECIATE SENATOR BRADFORD
LEADERSHIP IN THIS ISSUE TRYING
TO BREAK DOWN BARRIERS FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET EDUCATION
THAT JOB SKILLS PELUK
CONSERVATION COURSE PROVIDE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
HELPING. YOUNG PEOPLE GET THEIR
EDUCATION AIMED AT THOSE
IMPORTANT JOB SKILLS. ARGUMENT
RELIES ON THE SUPPORT OF THE
STATE THE PROGRAM THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR WE
PROCEED IF YOU SUPPORTED US
SEVENTY YEARS. AS A SENATOR
MENTION WILDFIRES CONCERNED ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE NEED TO THROW
EVERYTHING OUT THE PROBLEM.
YEAH WELL THIS IS A CHALLENGE
WE ALSO SEE THAT DEALING WITH
WILD FIRE DOES PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY TO
STRENGTHEN OUR ECONOMY. HOWEVER
WITHOUT A MAJOR LIKE SB SIX
NINE FOUR WE WON'T BE THINKING
ABOUT EQUITY IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THAT WORKFORCE. CORPS
MEMBERS ARE EXCITED TO
PARTICIPATE HELP THEIR
COMMUNITIES HOPE LOCAL
UTILITIES THAT SHOW OFF THEIR
SKILLS. ANY PARTICULAR THEY
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A SPECIALLY
BUILT PIPELINES TO UTILITIES
WHERE THEY CAN GET JOBS WHEN
THEY'RE DONE IN CORE MEMBERS.
SB SIX NINETY FOUR REINFORCES
THE URGENCY OF CREATING
PIPELINES TO ENSURE SUFFICIENT
WORKFORCE INSPECTOR BY
REQUIRING UTILITIES TO START
RECORDING AND IDENTIFYING YOUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES IN THIS AREA. THE
EXISTING SKILL SET RECORDS-
NEIGHBORS NOT ONLY ARE
BENEFICIAL TO YOU AT ELECTRIC
UTILITIES AND THE REPAIRS. BUT
THE MAKE UP OF THE CONSERVATION
CORPS CREWS ALSO DELIVER CLEAR
EQUITY BENEFIT CALIFORNIA BY
ELEVATING MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME YOUNG PEOPLE
AMONG OTHERS. IN STRONG.
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU I WILL NOW
TURN TO. NIKOLINA FERNANDES
WITH SEMPER- YOU WILL YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS NOT GOING
THAT'S NOT THAT GREAT SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED WE DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THAT THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS OR THE SUPPORT COMMON-
AND DO BELIEVE THAT DEVELOPING
A DIVERSE WORKFORCE IMPROVEMENT
OF ALL BACKGROUNDS AND
EXPERIENCES ESPECIALLY IN THE
WATER MITIGATION FAITH CRITICAL
AND TODAY AND WILL BE IN THE
FUTURE. AND WE JUST HAD SOME
REMAINING TECHNICAL CONCERNS
THAT WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON WOULD BE OFF DURING
A STAFF AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
ON JUNE TWENTY SECOND- AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. WILL NOW MOVE TO COMMENT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON SB SIX
NINETY FOUR IN THE CHAMBERS
SEEING NONE. AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES AT
A REMOTE LOCATION. SAY NINE.
PHONE MODERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
NINETY FOUR THE PUSH ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
NINE ZERO. YOU HAVE ONE LINE
QUEUING UP IT'LL TAKE JUST A
MOMENT. HEY WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
HERE WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE OH
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
YOUSEF MILLER WITH THE NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
TO BE JUST A SECOND HERE. THAT
SUPPORTER ACQUISITION OF A
SEVEN BILLION. SIX NINETY FOUR.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THE WEIGHT
HERE. OKAY NO THEY DID NOT
RESPOND SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO
NOT HAVING ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE
AT THE TIME. THANK YOU WILL NOW
BRING THE- CONVERSATION BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS C. NINE
THERE'S A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
FOR TO PASS THE SENATOR WE
ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE AND
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZING THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE ON
WILDFIRE MITIGATION EFFORTS AND
THEN MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE.
DIVERSITY AND THAT EFFORT IS
COMMENDABLE OUR MAJORITY LEADER
HAD A BILL I BELIEVE WITH SOME
SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO LOOK AT
DOING SIMILARLY SO- WE THANK
YOU- DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS THAT YOU LIKE TO SHARE
WITH US AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
THIS COMMITTEE'S THOUGHTFULNESS
ON THIS MEASURE AS STATED I
WORK FOR THE CONSERVATION CORPS
FOR NUMBER OF YEARS AND YOU CAN
FIND A MORE DEDICATED
HARDWORKING GROUP OF YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WANT TO GIVE
BACK. TO THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
THE STATE TO THE ENVIRONMENT
AND TO ALLOW THEM TO JUST
EXPAND AND- GROW PROFESSIONALLY
WITH BEING ABLE TO WORK FOR
UTILITY WOULD BE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- THE MOTION IS DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. I HAVE NUMBERS
SB SIX NINE FOR. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS WHOLE
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PERSON HI THERE CAN. BURKE
CARILLO CARRILLO I'D CHAO CHAO
AYE CHAN CHAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA
ASCENA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I AM MAYES MAYES
I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I WORK
QUIRK I REYES REYES I CHIANG.
CHIANG HI. IS THIRTEEN NO ZERO
YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU MR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- WILL NOW
TURN TO ITEM FOR A BELIEVE-
SENATOR STERN IS PRESENT THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIMPLY SENATE
BILL FOUR TWENTY THREE HI
ENERGY RENEWABLE AND ZERO
CARBON RESOURCES. CENTER STERN
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR EVER BEFORE I
BEGIN I JUST WANT TO. THE
COMMITTEE'S HARD WORK ON THIS
AND THE OTHER ITEMS THAT I
THINK IS ON YOUR CAN SECOND
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS YOU GUYS YOU ALL CAN
LOOK- PAGE SEVEN PAGE NINE-
DEFINING FIRM ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES TO INCLUDE GEOTHERMAL
REFLECTOR. ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE A MULTI DAY ENERGY
STORAGE- AND THEN TO STRIKE A
FAIR BIT OF THIS LEGISLATION
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR A FAIR BIT
IS BEING TAKEN OUT HERE- AND
THE REAL FOCUS IS GOING TO BE
ON THIS C. E. C. ASSESSMENT SO.
FOR THOSE OF YOU FOLLOWING
ALONG IN THE IN THE DETAILS- IN
SECTIONS TWO FIVE SIX AND
SEVEN- THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
STRUCK. AND SECTIONS AT WE'RE
GONNA FOLD SECTIONS THREE AND
FOUR INTO THE ASSESSMENT AND
ESSENTIALLY THE GOAL HERE IS
NOT TO- MAKE SOME- AND
UNNECESSARY INTERVENTION INTO
THE PUC'S I. R. P. PROCESS- OR
TO PUT ANY THUMBS ON ON THAT
SCALE- BUT TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT- THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IS LOOKING AT. A
VARIETY OF THESE FIRM ZERO
CARBON. RESOURCES TO BRING
BALANCE AND DIVERSITY TO OUR
PORTFOLIO SO HOPEFULLY WHEN WE
HAVE THESE EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS- VERY VERY HOT DAYS
WE'RE EXPERIENCING NOW AND IN
THE FUTURE IT HAS A HUGE IMPACT
ON OUR SYSTEM AND- ALL KINDS OF
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AND HOW
TO HAVE THAT BALANCE SYSTEM
WILL STILL CHEATING ARE- ARE
AGGRESSIVE RENEWABLES AND
EMISSIONS GOALS I THINK IS THE
GOAL OF THIS LEGISLATION WE DO
NOT WANT TO. BUILD OUT THE
FUTURE OF OUR POWER GRID TO BE
LIKE TEXAS I DON'T THINK WE
WANT TO LIVE. ON AN ISLAND IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE- WE'RE RELYING
SOLELY ON FOSSIL FUELS AND
HOPING THAT'LL GET US THROUGH
IT DIDN'T GET TEXAS THROUGH AND
IN IN OUR STATE IT'S BEEN
ACTUALLY A LOT OF THESE OTHER-
STRONG NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT
I'VE MENTIONED THAT. I THINK
WILL BUILD RESILIENCY IN THE
FUTURE AND ALSO CLEAN UP OUR
AIR SO. HAPPY TO GET INTO MORE
DETAILS OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
BUT WE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND SHARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR WE
ALWAYS APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
YOU AS WELL. WE HAVE IN THE
GALLERY- TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT JOHN
WHITE THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN
AND WE HAVE BEEN THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL- ORIGINALLY OF THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL WAS TO-
OVERCOME THE FACT THAT THE
MODELING THAT THE P. C. HAD
CONSIDERED. IN ITS R. P.
PROCESS DID NOT INCLUDE A
VALUATION OF A RANGE OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE THINK AND
OTHERS THINK- NEED TO BE PART
OF THAT THE DISCUSSION- BILLS
INCLUDE MULTI DAY AND SEASONAL
STORAGE. GEOTHERMAL OFFSHORE
WIND. ON THE NEED FOR DIVERSITY
AND BALANCE IN OUR PORTFOLIO
WAS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ON THE SP ONE
HUNDRED REPORT- AND SUGGESTIVE.
BOTH THE NEED FOR A DIVERSE
PORTFOLIO OF RENEWABLES AS WELL
AS FIRM ZERO CARBON RESOURCES.
THAT COULD HELP US BALANCE THE
GRID AND THIS BALANCE AND
DIVERSITY IS KEY ALONG WITH.
INCLUDING ATTRIBUTES. THAT THE
SYSTEM NEEDS AND ONE
OBSERVATION WE HAVE FROM OUR
EXPERIENCES THAT. NOT EVERY
RESOURCE HAS TO HAVE ALL THE
ATTRIBUTES THAT THE GRID NEEDS
BUT THE- COMBINED PORTFOLIO. OF
ATTRIBUTES HAS TO PRODUCE
WHAT'S NEEDED AND THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO. TO BROADEN OUR
THINKING A LITTLE BIT- OUR OUR
ORIGINAL GOAL WAS TO INFLUENCE
THE PLANNING PROCESS ON THE
OTHER P. AND THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY BOTH OF WHICH NEED TO
BE UP TO DATE. WITH THESE KINDS
OF. TECHNOLOGIES BUT FOR THE
MOMENT WE'RE LEFT WITH THIS
ASSESSMENT OF THE CDC. OF WHICH
WE HOPE CAN BE INCLUSIVE OF THE
FULL RANGE OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WE THINK WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
INTEREST. IN US AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ARE
NEXT WITNESS TO IN PERSON IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY THREE
IS DAN JACOBSON WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL CALIFORNIA. I
DON'T SEE HIM- WE HAVE BEEN
DOWN IS IN PERSON MAYBE CALL
THEN WILL LOOK TO THAT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TESTIFYING BY PHONE MODERATOR-
CAN YOU. ALERT PATRICK WELCH
WITH CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION HE MAY BE
BEGAN WITH HIS TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU MEDICARE THIS PATRICK WELCH
BUT THIS YEAR THE WAY WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL AND FRIENDS UNDERSTAND
THAT AMENDMENTS ARE BEING
ACCEPTED VIA THE MEDIA ANALYSIS
SHE MADE MEMBERS PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE POWER WE BELIEVE
THERE ARE THE STRONG PLANNING
AND REGULATORY MECHANISMS IN
PLACE THE STATE CLIMATE GOALS.
IN ASSESSING THE MERGING
TECHNOLOGIES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS WANT
THEIR FRIENDS AND HOPE TO
WITHDRAW OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. A BORG SOUTHERN.
EDISON YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. STE CATHERINE
BORG TURN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
CATHERINE BOARD AVAILABLE FOR
HER TESTIMONY. AS SOON I DO NOT
SEE HER SIGNED IN HERE ONLINE
OKAY THEN WE WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ON THIS BEFORE TWENTY THREE IN
THE CHAMBER SEEING ON AN
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AND REMOTE STATION.
NAY NONE BONE MODERATOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE AGAIN OF
THEM PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ONLY. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE THESE PRESS ONE TEN ZERO
YOU'LL GET YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
YOU'LL BE PUT BACK INTO Q.
THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO. AND WE
CAN START WITH ONE NUMBER
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS DISABILITY MANAGEMENT
SPENDING BILL GAS ELECTRIC WE
ARE PLANNING TO REMOVE UP IN
OPPOSITION TO DRAFTING NEUTRAL
GIVEN THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT
WILL CONTINUE TO REVIEW THOSE
AND- WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL BOTTOM
LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAN JACOBSON WITH
LEARNING CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
EARLIER ONE OF THE OTHER
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION I
POLICY I THINK WE COULD MAKE IT
THERE IN PERSON WE WERE
STUDYING THE AMENDMENTS UP
UNTIL JUST A COUPLE MINUTES AGO
I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL- THANKS TO THIS
CYNICAL. PHONY STRONG
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK. ON
TWITTER STUFF GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I APOLOGIZE I
COULD NOT BE THE FIRST NO
WORRIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU WITH A
BORDERLINE NUMBER ONE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WHO
CALPERS BOARD FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON SORRY FOR THE
CONFUSION EARLIER- WE- I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
ELEVEN THE PROPOSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND WITH
THAT WILL BE READY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY TWO PLEASE GLAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE WHEN ASKED
TO SPEAK WITH THE WHITE MAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF FORM ENERGY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER ONE EIGHT
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT KATHY MUCH
REPRESENTING PLUGIN AMERICANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. STE
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY THREE
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KATHY SHAKER OF SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VALERIE TERRELL OF
LOSSES WITH THE GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY- THANK YOU
COMMITTEE- AND AUTHOR OF THE
WORK DONE ON THE BILL IT
APPEARS THAT THE AMENDMENT
TAKEN ADDRESS- ARE MAJOR
CONCERNS IN THE FOURTEEN.
HUNDRED DILLON PLAN AND- LIKELY
LIMITING OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAROL LEAD IN BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY SAMPSON ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER AUTHORITY ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH PATRICK WELCH FOR
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES- ASSOCIATION AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AN AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THE MAN'S
WE LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING
AND HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AS
WELL. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF S. B. YOU FOUR TWENTY THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END OF
THE ROW. AND MISTER KERR WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE DR
COURT. ARM WELL FIRST ALL MOVE
THE BILL. WE HAVE AND THEN- I.
IT'S DISAPPOINTING TO LOSE
PARTS OF THE BILL FOR WHAT IT'S
WORTH I HAD A SIMILAR BILL TO
THE PARTS THAT YOU WERE REMOVED
AFTER TALKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF BUT ALSO AFTER
TALKING WITH THE C. P. U. C.
THEY'RE QUITE AWARE OF THIS
PROBLEM ALL IN THE NEED TO DO
THIS I TALKED PARTICULARLY
WITH. CLIFF RIGHT STARMAN AND
THE I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU
WERE MIGHT WANT TO TALK TO HIM
AS WELL I AM GOING TO BE
WRITING A LETTER GIVING MY
VIEWS ON THESE THINGS AND HE I
BELIEVE HE WILL BE. QUITE
PROACTIVE HE'S ALSO SUGGESTED
HE MAY NEED SOME LEGISLATION
FOR THE WRONG TO HELP HIM. IN
THE MISSION OF DOING THE THINGS
THAT YOU AND I BOTH WANT. AND
I. REQUEST THAT I PARTNER WITH
YOU ON IT. THANK YOU. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT AS A MEMBER
AND- YOUR LEADERSHIP THERE BUT
YES LET'S LET'S GO SENT A
LETTER AND HOPEFULLY A BILL TO.
MISTER MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CENTER STERN AYE I
FEEL YOUR PAIN- BUT- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS HERE
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS A- NOT
THE END OF IT HI. I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT TO. YOU AND
YOUR SUPPORTERS ARE AWARE OF.
YOU KNOW- MY EXPERIENCE ON THIS
ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT. WHERE WE
HAVE THE OF REDONDO BEACH
NATURAL GAS POWER PLANT. THAT-
FOR TEN YEARS YOU KNOW THE CPC
THE ENERGY COMMISSION. THEY
THEY THEY THEY HAD TEN YEARS TO
PLAN FOR THE- DECLARED A
DEADLINE TO SHUT DOWN THE ONCE
THROUGH COOLING NATURAL GAS
POWER PLANTS- THE BASE THE
STATE WATER BOARD ESTABLISHED
THE POLICY IN NINETEEN TEN IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE SHUT DOWN
BY. THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
BUT WE WERE HIT WITH THESE-
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS ARE
A COMBINED WITH OF COURSE YOU
KNOW ANOTHER SEASON OF A OF A
TERRIFYING WILDFIRES. NOTED TO
COME THIS YEAR AND SO. YOU KNOW
HAD AT SOME POINT. THEY'VE HAD
ENOUGH TIME TO- SHUT DOWN THESE
FOSSIL FUEL BURNING- YOU KNOW
ENERGY- NOTE LOAD SERVING-
OPERATIONS A IN IN THIS CASE
THAT THE COSTA ONE THREE
COOLING POWER PLANT. AND SO
YOUR BILL CLEARLY IS PUSHING
YOU KNOW OUR STATE REGULATORS-
AND YOU KNOW TO IDENTIFY AND
PLAN FOR MORE OF THESE. HIS
FIRM- ZERO CARBON. ALTERNATIVES
AND I FULLY SUPPORT THAT I JUST
SHARE THAT EXPERIENCE AS A
CAUTIONARY TALE THAT THAT WE
CAN. YOU KNOW PUT ALL OF OUR WE
CAN'T OVER RELY ON OUR STATE
REGULATORS WHEN OUR STATE
REGULATORS HAVE FAILED TO
BALANCE THE- THE NEEDS FOR OUR-
OUR GREAT. RELIABILITY WITH OUR
COMMITMENT TO FACE OUT OUR
FOSSIL FUEL. ENERGY PRODUCTION.
THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE A WE
APPRECIATE FIRST OF ALL WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR BILL- WE
ALSO APPRECIATE AS A COMMITTEE
YOUR- YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
FOCUS ON- THE KIND OF- EFFORTS
THAT NEED TO BE PURSUED- WE
DON'T DISAGREE- BUT AS MISTER
MURATSUCHI KIND OF HOW IT
HIGHLIGHTED USING NATURAL GAS
AS SORT OF THE FOCAL POINT- IF
WE SAY TOMORROW. OR TODAY. OR
YESTERDAY THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO RELY ON NATURAL GAS AT ALL.
THEN HOW DO THE ENERGY AGENCIES
PREPARE TODAY. FOR THE IMPACT
ON OUR GRID THAT'S HAPPENING
TODAY. WE'RE OVER THE WEEKEND
THERE WAS A HUNDRED AND EIGHT
OR IF NOT HIGHER IN PORTLAND
OREGON. SO THESE RE REALITIES
THAT ARE IN GOLF IN OUR POLICY
CONVERSATIONS. AND I THINK WE
ALL ARE IN SPIRITUAL ALIGNMENT.
WITH SOME MURATSUCHI AND
CERTAINLY WITH THE HEART OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS COMMITTEE ALSO
MOVED FOR- NOTWITHSTANDING THE
EFFORTS THAT WERE ALREADY UNDER
WAY WITH THE C. C. ON OFFER
WITH- WE DO WORK WITH RECOGNIZE
AND APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THIS BASELOAD. NAY SIXPENCE IN
TERMS OF TAKING ON OTHER ISSUES
WE'VE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
WITH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA ON
HIS LONG STANDING COMMITMENT
AND FIGHT FOR GEOTHERMAL- WE'RE
LOOKING AT LEAST THE- MY NAME
DOWN IN THE AREA AS WELL AND SO
I THINK THAT. THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT YOU'RE EMBRACING WE DON'T
DISAGREE WITH- BUT AS WE TRY O
NAVIGATE SOME OF THESE RIGHT
NOW- CHALLENGES- CAN I KNOW
YOUR YOUR COLLEAGUES- CENTER
SKINNER WAS HERE A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO WITH A HYDROGEN GREEN
HYDROGEN BILL WHICH WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT. SO IT'S NOT
AS THOUGH THAT THE COMMITTEE
DOESN'T APPRECIATE EMBRACE- THE
BROADER INTERVIEW CONVERSATIONS-
WE JUST HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
CHALLENGES THAT ARE EVEN AS WE
SPEAK WE WERE PREPARING FOR THE
SUMMER READING THIS BASED ON
WHAT HAPPENED LAST AUGUST.
THAT'S OLD NEWS NOW. NOW WE GOT
TO DEAL WITH AN EVER CHANGING
SET OF THE RUBIK'S CUBE AS WE
NOW TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
NOW PREPARE FOR THIS SUMMER
READING THIS. WITH A WHOLE NEW
SHIFT IN THE IN THE PARADIGM.
AND SO WE'RE- NAVIGATING AND I
THINK AS AS AGGRESSIVELY AS WE
CAN UNDER SOME CONSTRAINTS OF.
REALITY BUT I THINK WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT- VISIONARY
THINKING AND PLANNING AS PART
OF THE QUESTION AS WELL SO WITH
THAT WE SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND
WE SUPPORT THE HOPE OF THE-
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
AS WE GO FORWARD IN THIS
CONVERSATION. TO SEE US MAYBE
BE ABLE TO BE IN A BETTER
POSITION TO START EMBRACING.
EVEN MORE AGGRESSIVELY SOME OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO GET OUT
WITH THAT- I'M NOT SURE IF WE
HAVE A MOTION RUMORS. YES DR
COURT. AND MAJORITY LEADER
RAMOS HAVE MADE THE MOTION SO-
LET'S KEEP WORKING TOGETHER.
WILL CALL THE ROLL ON THE
MOTION. I'D OF NUMBER FOUR. SB
FOUR TWO THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOT VOTING
POWER CAN. PARA QUE HAN I BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO I CHAO
CHAO AYE CHAN. CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I'D
MAYES MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I WORK. QUIRK I
BREA'S REYES I CHIANG. TANG HAI
IS THIRTEEN NO ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THE BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU I WILL MOVE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR TODAY
IN TERMS OF ITEMS THAT- FOR
PRESENTATION I WILL NOW. WE'RE
BACK TO OUR CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT WILL WORK OUR WAY BACK
THROUGH THE FILE TO GIVE
MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD
ON WHO HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY VOTE. AS OF THIS
POINT SO MADAM SECRETARY LET'S
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND THEN WE WILL MOVE. TO THE
FILE. I HAD A NUMBER TO AN ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. SB NINETY NINE SB
FIVE THIRTY THREE. BURKE BURKE
I. CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I IS FIFTEEN NO
ZERO. CONSENT FILE IS OUT. YES
SIR OKAY FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILL
ITSELF. ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
SIXTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA I IS
FIFTEEN NO. ZERO BECAUSE
FIFTEEN NO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE. SB TWO TWO
TWO THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE I. IS TWELVE NO. ZERO AND
THREE NOT VOTING. FEDERAL ZERO
THREE THE BILL IS OUT. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. SB FOUR TWO THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
CHEN. IS THIRTEEN NO ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL INTO. K.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB SIX NINE FOR
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS BARRICADE CAN.
PARA QUE HAN I BURKE BURKE AYE
AYES FIFTEEN NO ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT. OKAY THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING FOR THE
DAY. THE COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.